hola muy buenas noches gracias por
continuar en la pantalla de france en 24
estamos de regreso para actualizar las
principales noticias en materia
económica junto por supuesto a daniela
blandón daniela muy buenas noches
ayer domingo finalizó lo que fue la
cumbre del g7 y luego llegó toda una
catarata de críticas verdad de los
resultados del encuentro en santiago muy
buenas noches mira el término de la
reunión de tres días de los líderes de
las naciones más ricas del mundo sean
usuario se ha anunciado en varias cosas
entre ellas que acogen la propuesta de
un impuesto global corporativo y que
ayudarán con vacunas a los países pobres
sin embargo recibieron muchas críticas
sobre este último punto comenzando por
la organización mundial de la salud
auel candesa por the express acojo con
satisfacción el apoyo expresado por el
g7 lado ms y acojo con satisfacción el
anuncio de que los países del g7 donarán
870 millones de dosis de vacunas
principalmente a través de covas esto es
de gran ayuda pero necesitamos más y lo
necesitamos más rápido fácil no tengo
más santiago human rights watch calificó
la cumbre de colosal fracaso recordó que
querían comprometer mil millones de
dosis y que aún esa cifra era
insuficiente porque el mundo necesita al
menos 11 veces esa cantidad por su parte
la ong oxfam criticó el hecho de que los
países más poderosos digan que quieren
vacunar al mundo de aquí al final de año
cuando sus acciones muestran que les
importa más proteger los monopolios y
las patentes de las gigantes
farmacéuticas
bueno hablando daniela de lo que es el
acceso a las vacunas contra el kobe 19
la organización mundial del comercio
está urgiendo a todos sus miembros para
que se acuerde la liberación de la
patente finalmente y de una vez
claro pues la jefa de esta organización
mundial del comercio a negocio con yo
igual
quiere que haya un acuerdo antes de
julio para que las grandes farmacéuticas
renuncien a sus derechos de propiedad
intelectual sobre las vacunas y es que
las conversaciones llevan meses y no hay
un acuerdo a la vista santiago la
mayoría de países en desarrollo apoyan
la exención pero no así los países ricos
que alegan que las investigaciones que
llevaron a la inoculación en tiempo
récord justamente se financian de esta
manera con patentes la oim s agregó que
las barreras comerciales relacionadas
con los suministros médicos utilizados
contra el cob y 19 han aumentado
drásticamente en los últimos meses en
lugar de disminuir como se esperaría una
polémica que veremos cómo se desenvuelve
daniela vamos ahora a líbano para hablar
de la crisis económica que sigue
agudizándose verdad en este país
santiago pues la moneda local volvió a
caer a un mínimo histórico frente al
dólar en el mercado ilegal hoy un dólar
cuesta 15 mil 400 libras es decir la
libra ha perdido un 90 por ciento de su
valor frente a octubre de 2019 que fue
cuando recordemos estallaron las
protestas contra
la situación empeora con el pasar de los
días en este país hay una grave escasez
de combustible y productos básicos como
los medicamentos además los cortes de
electricidad duran gran parte del día en
medio de una crisis económica que
santiago el banco mundial ha calificado
como una de las peores que ha visto el
mundo en los últimos 150 años que diga
la situación vamos a cambiar de tema
para hablar de lo que son las remesas
enviadas a centroamérica que se
dispararon no de lo que fueron los
primeros meses de 2021 claro estos son
los emigrantes radicados en el exterior
sobre todo en eeuu pues se incrementaron
drásticamente sus envíos a sus
respectivos países según datos
recopilados por los bancos centrales en
donde más crecieron entre enero y mayo
fue en república dominicana con más del
60 por ciento hasta 4.400 millones de
dólares honduras se recibió como vemos 2
mil 800 millones en los primeros cinco
meses con un 45 por ciento más que en el
mismo periodo de 2006 guatemala tuvo un
aumento similar y los envíos sumaron kim
5600 millones y en guatemala la cifra
más reciente disponibles a abril y hasta
momento las remesas tenían un alza del
23 por ciento y que nos dicen los
indicadores de la jornada esta semana
los ojos están puestos en la reunión de
la reserva federal en wall street en los
índices standard and poor's y el
tecnológico nasdaq marcaron un nuevo
récord histórico en europa algunos de
los principales mercados también
terminaron en máximos y también en
latinoamérica o avances la bolsa de sao
paulo estuvo cerca del nuevo récord
finalizamos con algo que muchísimas
personas están esperando las cifras del
día 28 millones de dólares santiago en
ese valor se subastó un asiento al lado
del multimillonario jeff besos para el
viaje turístico inaugural que hará su
empresa blue o beijing al espacio al
próximo mes y dio no por supuesto que si
yo me anoto muchísimas gracias dan y
hasta aquí la información económica en
france 24 sigan informando se en el
resto de nuestra programación gracias
por acompañarnos